Andrew on absolutely Wild game but it
was all about Josiah's early on pressure
due to his opening preparation I mean
you had to make some difficult decisions
along the way what was your first
reaction after this move F6 because
black can play E6 G6 you've played
against those but not against F6 take us
through your reaction
um when he played F6 I recalled vaguely
that this move is maybe possible but um
it shouldn't be great but obviously had
I had to start thinking from what's this
move seven so
um I'll just try to play
um you know what seemed logical to me
but you know I was prepared that you
know he probably looked at stuff so I'd
have to continue playing Under Pressure
which isn't which isn't fun but um and
that's exactly what happened right and
at this point you had the opportunity to
repeat the position yeah right and then
go with Bishop to D4 Rook to B8 you
could still go Bishop to Ace seven and
that would have ended the game but that
doesn't help you in the standings right
you're still playing for the national
title how did you come to the conclusion
that down an hour on the clock you have
to find something well actually the
decision was like less about the
standings in the tournament I was just
like
a bit and I've been quite upset if I had
to just make a draw with white
um
where he had been basically didn't have
to do anything so I felt like okay I'm
you know I might as well just
go for it go for it and see what happens
and there's a lot going on here I have a
lot of options on G3 rookie one Knight
takes C6 a lot to calculate but um yeah
all of them weren't so clear to me
um for instance like one line here
rookie one looks very natural but
um just here after B5 it's the position
this I wasn't completely sure about
um
why it gets like two pieces I mean rook
in two pawns for two pieces but but for
rookie one actually the bigger issue was
I calculated Bishop D6 he has so I take
on C6 now the idea is he cannot take
back because with the pawn because
Bishop 695 with the double pin
um
that's the point very nice but uh yeah
but after Bishop V6 he has I think
Bishop takes Knight x66 Bishop Ford
check King B1 Queen C6 establish of a
seven here
um Bishop Bishop A7 the little doubles
around the rook and the bishop but here
I thought black at least can take on A4
Knight takes Rook a knight B6 yeah Rook
A7 Rook Knight C8 Rook a knight B6 Rook
T8 and black is definitely not worse
here so a lot of I I can't go for this
wild stuff yeah long wild stuff breaks I
calculate a lot but none of them seem so
satisfactory to me so I just took on C6
and played between five and was like
okay I might I don't think I have
anything here but I might as well just
play yeah this is you know tame the
position a little bit make sure you're
not getting checkmated you're not losing
any pieces and just play the game as it
is make natural moves right put the
hooks on the open files and it was this
moment I mean you played F5 with only
six minutes on the Block and he found
some really good moves yeah but it was
at this point after C4 where he got
greedy with this move Queen to F6 yeah I
mean
I I totally understand his logic um I
had like no time on my clock he had over
an hour yes and my king is so weak um
but yeah this move looks very tempting
but I've seen that I had at least rookie
three here did you see this from afar
yeah we're calculating this calculator
and also I was hoping you would go into
this I wasn't completely sure that maybe
I missed something but
to what I saw I didn't see
um a clear way for black to take
advantage of this so when I saw queen of
six the guy I played rookie three and um
I have everything under control actually
I I had uh forgotten this move Rook
before exists out of time
um but luckily I have Queen takes A6
which is and now the best movie it was a
bit crazy it was Queen to d8 yeah did
you even consider this move or you
weren't looking at in this direction no
I wasn't really looking at that um I
thought about Queen A1 shot that's yeah
and there's a lot going on Queen D4 Rook
E1 and I saw C4 Bishop G6 but take on G6
I I thought okay I probably shouldn't be
risking anything but positions still
very complicated so anything can happen
I mean with such a naked King right yeah
but but I thought to myself that you
know at least I get to make a lot of
moves and get closer time yeah some time
on the clock yeah I might as well just
go for this and this was the big mistake
after Queen to G5 already things are
turning your way uh quite clearly
because you have this idea with Queen to
H4 exchange the queens and this is an
easy end game huge important victory for
you Andrew tomorrow only half a point
most likely behind the leader going into
the final one who are you playing
tomorrow I'm playing
oh that's a big matchup big head to head
what is your uh General experience with
um who is one of your good friends yeah
it's one of my good friends I know
generally
um I do well against him for whatever
reason but uh you know that doesn't mean
anything for tomorrow's game and
you know I'll just you know do my best
and
I mean to be in this position uh
considering what I did yesterday this is
a little bit a little bit of improvement
so I'll take it absolutely Andrew
congratulations we'll see you tomorrow
thank you
our congratulations as well Andrew as
well